شبح المجاعه يلوح بالافق في السودان مع
استمرار الاشتباكات وغياب اي بوادر لحل
قريب
[موسيقى]
اتصالي في برنامج الاغذيه العالميه
لنيكنزلي وصفت الوضع الانساني في السودان
بالكارثي
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي يشدد على ضروره
وقف القتال اولا لتمكين ايصال مساعدات
الانسانيه بامان
قلق وخوف وخيمان ايضا من ارتفاع جنوني في
اسعار المواد الغذائيه والوقود
برنامج الاغذيه العالميه اكد ان
المستودعات التابعه له نهبت واخرى تعرضت
للقصر
بينما دمرت طائره تابعه لخدمات النقل
الجويه التابعه للامم المتحده في مطار
الخرطوم الدولي
ارقام فلكيه قد تستمر في الازدياد في ظل
الحرب الجايه
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات